oui bonsoir Patrice alors vous en parlez
depuis des mois ou de 7 ans la pandémie
qui s'est transformée puis vous disiez
beaucoup c'est pas du jour au lendemain
que ça devient endémique mais c'est un
processus voici que l'OMS disent que
vous dites depuis un bout de temps ça
veut dire quoi pour nous docteur Carvin
qu'est-ce que ça change
ça change que là il faut comprendre que
la covid-19 va rester dans notre
environnement elle ne disparaîtra pas
donc la fin de la pandémie ça veut pas
dire la fin de la covid donc on va vivre
encore des peut-être à un moment donné
des temps un peu sous tension lorsqu'on
aura peut-être un nouveau variant ou
lorsque dans certaines places sur la
planète il y aura potentiellement des
problèmes mais ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que revenir à une étape de
couvre-feu de fermeture de la société de
ne plus voyager de diminution de
l'activité économique c'est très fort
probablement une quelque chose du passé
qui ne sera plus dans nos tableaux et la
fermeture par exemple des écoles le
travail en télétravail pour l'ensemble
de la population etc ce sont
probablement des choses qui a grande
échelle n'arriveront plus pourquoi parce
que là on voit que globalement pour
l'immense majorité des gens quand ils
font la covid ils sont peu malades bien
sûr il faut regarder ça à l'échelle
sociétale toujours des exceptions il y a
toujours des groupes à risques mais pour
l'ensemble de la population aujourd'hui
si vous voulez la covid a été jusqu'à un
certain point dompté et on a aussi
beaucoup d'outils à part les vaccins les
traitements etc pour pouvoir faire de la
covid quelque chose qui est gérable et
qui ne fait pas écrouler notre système
de santé vous dites parmi les outils que
nous avons il y a les vaccins est-ce que
les vaccins sont la principale cause du
fait qu'il n'y a plus beaucoup de gens
très malades
alors tout à fait la grande victoire
vous dirait entre ce qu'on a vécu durant
la première la deuxième vague et
aujourd'hui c'est la vaccination de la
population donc on sait qu'aujourd'hui
les vaccins nous protègent pas contre
l'infection mais que la population
vaccinée lorsqu'elle est bien protégée
par ses vaccins là et lorsqu'elle
attrape la covid ne développe plus une
maladie sévère comme elle faisait dans
le passé et c'est très évident
aujourd'hui on voit des gens qui il y a
deux ans si ils avaient attrapé la covid
on les a vu mais dans des conditions
beaucoup plus sévères et aujourd'hui on
voit des gens âgés malades etc
triplement vacciner quadruplement
vacciné qui lorsqu'ils font la covid
sont relativement peu malades donc il y
a eu un changement important je vous
dirais de la pathogénicité donc de la
maladie en tant que telle qu'on ne
voyait pas auparavant et qui est dû en
très grosse partie au vaccin et surtout
pour la population à risque c'est ça
qu'il faut souligner d'ailleurs
une parenthèse vous vous dites depuis un
certain temps ceux qui doivent aller
chercher la quatrième et même la
cinquième dose ce sont les personnes à
risque parce que quelqu'un qui est très
en santé vous vous dites vous pouvez
attendre
tout à fait vous savez on a appliqué
avec réseau au début de la pandémie la
même recette à tout le monde que vous
ayez 18 ans et que vous soyez en pleine
forme ou que vous ayez 102 ans dans un
CHU SLD tout le monde avait le même
format si on fait pas toujours en
médecine de façon évident aujourd'hui
avec l'expérience et l'apprentissage
puis c'était très correct au passage de
le faire on doit comprendre que par
exemple quelqu'un de en santé qui a pas
de facteur de risque qui est
relativement jeune qui a eu trois doses
de vaccins et qui a eu la covid en plus
ou qui a eu deux doses de vaccins qui a
eu la covid on va dire depuis le mois de
décembre 2021 que ces gens là le risque
d'attraper la covid est présent mais le
risque de faire une covid sévère et
relativement faible et relativement même
très faible pour beaucoup de ces gens là
donc avec l'arrivée de nouveaux vaccins
qu'on appelle des vaccins bivalents qui
sont une forme améliorée des vaccins du
passé donc des formes 2.0 de ces vaccins
là et surtout avec une arrivée
potentielle de encore meilleur
ça on va dire sans vouloir rentrer dans
des données très techniques d'ici
janvier février 2023 alors pour la
majorité de ces gens là le fait d'aller
chercher une dose supplémentaire de
rappel aujourd'hui aura relativement peu
d'impact en termes de leur risque de
sévérité de la maladie c'est ça vous
êtes si vous voulez y aller allez-y ça
c'est pas mauvais mais ceux qui doivent
vraiment y aller c'est les gens qui sont
soit très âgés ou à risque avec des
maladies sous-jacentes etc docteur Weiss
mais les indicateurs sur la planète
baise partout même malheureusement
là où on n'a pas de temps vacciné
comment ça se fait
c'est parce que il faut voir où est-ce
qu'il n'a pas été tant vacciné d'abord
il faut faire attention aux indicateurs
parce qu'on ne teste plus aujourd'hui
comment tester au début de la pandémie
on le voit bien au Québec aussi
lorsqu'on testait vous vous rappelez au
début de la pandémie on avait une image
beaucoup plus claire de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on ne teste que des groupes
très à risque et très ciblés avec des
techniques PCR et on laisse les gens
s'auto tester donc les groupes ne sont
plus tout à fait comparables par contre
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il y a une
diminution importante des
hospitalisations à peu près partout sur
la planète mais une des conséquences je
vous dirais de ça c'est le fait qu'on a
vacciné aussi beaucoup la population il
faut faire aussi attention on peut pas
comparer tous les pays les uns aux
autres il y a des pays qui sont qui ont
une population relativement jeune et des
pays qui ont une population beaucoup
plus âgée et donc par exemple de
comparer certains pays comme l'Italie ou
la moyenne d'âge est élevée avec des
pays beaucoup plus jeunes c'est pas
totalement quelque chose qu'on peut
faire de façon adéquate pour Extrapol
des résultats mais ce qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'avec un monde qui est beaucoup
plus ouvert imaginez-vous quand le
Québécois ne voyagez pas n'allait pas à
l'extérieur alors qu'aujourd'hui on voit
qu'il y a un retour quasiment normal au
voyage
aux activités normales etc aux activités
culturelles sportives et c'est tant
mieux et on ne voit pas d'impact majeur
sur le système hospitalier comme on
voyait au début et en plus l'immense
majorité des gens qu'on hospitalise
aujourd'hui et qui testent positif pour
la covid non pas d'un covid comme
diagnostic principal de leur
hospitalisation bien souvent ils
arrivent à l'hôpital pour une cause qui
est autre alors il ne faut pas minimiser
la covid on a encore probablement des
choses à voir mais il va falloir aborder
le problème de façon différente entre
autres par exemple au niveau des
isolements est-ce qu'on doit garder par
exemple des travailleurs de la santé
triplement vaccinés qui sont très peu
malades qui test positives et qu'on
garde chez eux pendant 10 jours alors
que ces gens-là manquent terriblement au
réseau de la santé et qu'aujourd'hui
avec le port du masque les mesures de
prévention et contrôle des infections
ces gens-là pourraient revenir au
travail beaucoup plus rapidement c'est
ce que déjà beaucoup de juridiction dans
le monde commencent à faire l'Ontario
d'ailleurs le fait déjà docteur Weiss en
deux mots vous aviez raison d'être plus
optimiste parce qu'il y a des gens qui
vous écoutent
il est assez optimiste docteur Weiss je
l'ai entendu à votre émission vous aviez
raison d'être optimiste quand même
il faut être optimiste vous savez dans
l'histoire toutes les pandémies ont fini
par finir la preuve c'est que nous
sommes là aujourd'hui et on a surmonté
toutes les pandémies et on a des outils
technologiques aujourd'hui comme on n'a
jamais eu dans le passé en termes de
vaccination de traitement la quantité de
nouveaux médicaments qui arrivent dans
le pipeline est énorme et donc il faut
être optimiste moi j'ai vu la covid à la
première vague j'ai vu la covid cet été
ça veut pas dire qu'on n'aura pas des
écueils et des obstacles sur le chemin
qu'on n'aura pas peut-être des périodes
difficiles qu'on prend pas des éclosions
dans les écoles etc mais le monde qu'on
a connu en 2020
n'existera plus dans les dans l'état
actuel avec la covid à mon sens on se
laisse sur cette belle phrase docteur
kervas microbiologie s'affectionneur de
l'Hôpital général juif merci beaucoup de
nous avoir parlé encore une fois
ça fait plaisir bonne soirée